[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker
and last week we published an episode
called convivial games portray war
better and surprisingly it wasn't as
contentious as we thought it was but I
think it was definitely a most critical
one yet
aside from the Mass Effect one which was
just kind of critical because I was down
on Mass Effect this was just more
actually like how can the wider genre
sorry medium of video games do better at
portraying war which they do often but I
don't think they do well and we
highlight again so we thought could do
well and we got a lot of questions and
so we'll jump right into those thank you
so much as usual in these off week
episodes being a biweekly show we like
to I could like to give Jake a chance to
talk about the game or whatever we
talked about last episode because most
of time this is my opinion that might
change in the future we're working on
those things but we did want to get
right into questions thanks so much for
YouTube's comment your tweets we have a
few up here so just jump right in
alright first one is David Miller he
says what are some story beats or
gameplay mechanics that you guys think
would make for a more realistic slash
less sensationalized war game while also
making for a fun video game that's tough
this is really tough straddling the line
between fun I don't think I don't think
I can be like an actual right off the
bat I don't think any games ever it's
never going to place us in war there's
no substitute for I even like VR will
never actually place us into a place
where we're afraid of dying and like
[ __ ] people at war have to see I didn't
want to say that during that episode
because I know that won't happen but in
terms of a game because games kind of
inherently have to be they don't have to
be fun which is actually what we want to
we'll get into that but they kind of
have to at least as a war game have like
make use of the agency and Mayweather
that's like making it fun or that's
actually like criticizing your actions
like you didn't SpecOps which we touched
on the episode it's tough to straddle
that line between entertainment and
actual realism you know like you know
like ARMA and hardcore mods like that I
actually got into for a while and then I
couldn't because you really have to get
into him but I think those are the
better ones where in terms of you
actually have to manage like supplies
you have to manage
even like psychological stuff I think
XCOM and what else making a fire emblem
that's they're kind of good about
talking about the psychological impact
on these people like showing how in a
strategy genre not necessarily shooters
but these specific soldiers can panic or
can be green and it's gamified but at
least I'd like to see more on that like
the actual psychological effects of this
kind of stuff yeah I think I agree with
that but I think when talking about
mechanics I think some things that could
make them more interesting I think is
fragility of life right like end games
like Call of Duty you seem to take a lot
of bullets than you heal over time which
is fine that makes it fun but I do enjoy
those experiences where you really have
to worry about getting shot I mean a
recent game is Rainbow six siege head
shots kill one shot and that's very
different stacked achill shooter but I
think a war game could do something like
that another idea that I actually just
thought of on the spot here would be
there isn't really like a roguelike war
game really and that could be kind of
cool you know you die as one come back
play yet another one coincidentally did
you ever hear Hideo Kojima's idea for a
game he wanted to make a game back in
the day and I don't know if he actually
pitched it to Konami don't take my word
for it but go look this up he wanted to
make a game where if you die the disk
either the disc like will stop working
like it's permadeath
until you spend like whatever games were
at that point like a ps1 game was and
that sounds crazy like it sounds cool
like I guess like an ARMA it's kind of
yeah ARMA is a good mom but yeah that'd
be cool
but in terms of roguelikes yeah I mean
aside from like 2d platformers that'd be
really interesting to see people go yeah
kind of you know start over and like
actually portray in a realistic way and
kind of make you really not want to die
yeah I think that would be a good
mechanic to have an organ
next one is does the fact that while
Williams who wrote SpecOps is writing
Battlefront 2 with Mitch dire does n
callous hope of you hope yes that's
actually that's really cool so Mitch
dire knows his Star Wars really well and
he's a great writer we used to like kind
of be colleagues with him when he was
over at IGN but he's since joined EA
motive and he's working on that with
Walt Williams who like this person said
is very well-versed in you know maybe
what we talked about that episode with
SpecOps kind of make you question your
actions so I don't know they're they're
doing the whole boots-on-the-ground
thing for battlefront 2 but they're
showing from the Empire's percept
perspective which is cool and that's
something we don't usually see in Star
Wars and you know that could be that
could be an interesting way to tackle
the post for the Jedi pre force awakens
conflicts yeah when we were first
discussing this episode you we both
brought up SpecOps line and you actually
mentioned Walt Williams at the time too
and I think at the time did we know he
was actually working on battlefront -
yeah like tentatively I didn't know like
how many people were involved in writing
it but um yeah cuz I knew like once
Mitch Dyer had joined I'd heard of all
Williams was also doing it - yeah well
writing this I we definitely looked a
lot at spec ops the line and I think
that is definitely one of the more
powerful examples and the fact that he
is working on battlefront - even though
it isn't like a it's a Star Wars war
game I think that shows a lot of
potential yeah I mean we talked about it
in the war episode last week's episode
that just because Gears of War in halo
our science fiction doesn't mean that
their stories are not you know
commenting on real things just like we
talked to uh could we talk it was it was
Thomas Paine who wrote that book who we
looked up but there I had read for this
episode and saying you know that just
because there's not realism involved
that's like why call duty what's the
future because they were getting too
much pushback and they were kind of like
political ramifications of
you know the conflicts in Afghanistan
and Iraq we're becoming even more
complicated by the day so like why the
[ __ ] are we portraying this in a video
game and having you shoot these people
when you're seeing this on CNN every day
I think that's why they went to the
future and now they're going back to
World War two which is good time pegged
for this episode it turns out but yeah I
am excited to see how Star Wars might be
knowing Walt Williams past work and
Mitch's past work I'm really excited to
see how they apply Star Wars to to like
you know video games in general but also
just what they could say with it yeah it
gives them a really good opportunity to
humanize the enemy possibly and kind of
play with some of the morale the other
the morale things that the Empire faces
which you kind of don't really get much
insight into it's like oh these are the
bad guys they're doing bad things so
yeah good could be interesting and yeah
that last question was from John
shukroon on Twitter apologies from
completely butchering renamed please
respond to me on Twitter after this
episode let me know how to say it
because we always appreciate your input
last one we want talk about today is
more of a critique which we always
appreciate Stephen Westcott on YouTube
said maybe you failed to mention
battlefield one yes it made war fun but
even more so it portrayed the chaos and
horrors of war the soundtrack sets a
somber an ominous tone of the events
you're about to undertake the weapons
are frustrating it terrifying you can
almost always get in a situation where
you have no idea what's going on I get
where you're coming from I disagree I
mean that Italian campaign you're wading
across this battlefield in this like
pseudo suit of armor with a machine gun
just mowing people down in the
Australian campaign you're this like
lone wolf hero who yeah they try to
humanize it with the kid who you're kind
of recruiting but you're this Australian
messenger and you're a runner and you're
you're going back and forth between
these like all-out battles with these
enable things the the actual American
campaign they try to say stuff about
like what it means to actually like
sacrifice yourself and then you have a
character next you who doesn't want to
do it I think they touch on it I think
battlefield one glorified it more than
any game I've played recently I think
battlefield one made more war look good
yeah that opening intro you're
everybody's dying but I get it it was
pretty a ham-fisted way to say it it
would say like whatever like John Smith
18 years old or whatever yeah like
No 1903 to 1918 or something I don't
know um yeah this I think
battlefield one kind of purported to be
humanizing and decrying war but I don't
think it did that at all yeah I I think
there for me at least there was
definitely disconnect between the story
they were trying to tell and then what
you actually would play and like what
you're talking about the Italian
campaign the story for that I remember
actually being kind of cool it was about
this grandfather who finds memorabilia
or something like that and then it kind
of goes back in time and takes a look at
takes a look at that and that idea is
cool and they're talking about how war
is hell essentially but then when you
play it yeah you're in a suit of armor
you're mowing down things with a machine
gun it's it's a bit ridiculous and once
again I think both of us like I I
enjoyed I didn't play all the campaigns
in battlefield 1 but I played some of
and I did enjoy the ones I play but
ghast ralien won the Italian one and
there's another one I played and they
were they were all a lot of fun but I
think for what we were going for with
this episode of reboot I just don't
think battlefield 1 really fit yeah
no I mean I love that one I think it's a
very fun game multiplayer especially but
like you said I think you put it better
than I did there's definitely weird
juxtaposition between what they were
telling you and what you were doing for
sure but yes anyway Stephen Westcott
thank you for your input and I
appreciate your point of view like even
if we disagree I completely
wholeheartedly get why battlefield 1 is
impactful for a lot of people so thank
you very much for comment um anyway I
guess we could talk about what we're
doing for the next episode of reboot
yeah kind of
you know catapulting from this episode
we're gonna do one on do video games
need to be fun and I'm sure they're
gonna be a lot of comments just one word
yes but uh we're gonna dive into games
that aren't necessarily made to be fun
I've got a few off top my head right now
but I don't want to spoil it you know
they're probably people can probably
guess a few we want to talk about in
recent years but I think more and more
games don't always need to be made to be
fun they could just like convey
something using player agency and it's
really interesting
I love
games obviously we just talked about
battlefield one I had a lot of fun with
that we'd probably like titanfall to
later been playing persona 5 which is
really fun for me but I do want to look
at what games can be outside of fun I
think it's a really important thing
especially when you want to take a
deeper look at our medium which is that
alone it's fun but I could be helpful
yeah what's interesting too is I don't
know how much of the comments you looked
through for this latest episode but that
did get brought up some one was
something like do games need to be fun
like movies aren't always fun to watch
yet they're good yeah I would never
watch the revenant again in my life yeah
which will probably mention that in the
next episode now that I say it but yeah
like not all I think like the older of
medium gets the less it needs to just
focus on being just entertaining or just
fun I think you do more than that I
think games you know I'm not crusader I
really enjoy fun games but I think games
have a lot of potential to keep pushing
the bounds of what they can be oh yeah
for everybody who got YouTube comments
and tweeted at us about last episode or
suggested episode ideas for the future
or just critiqued or had questions thank
you so much for the best part the show
we really enjoy these more laid-back Q&A
off week episodes of course we're going
to get to work on the next episode and
be sure as always to get YouTube
comments tweets in comments on Gamescom
we appreciate them and we always look
forward to your insight until then we'll
see you next week
[Music]